a court has ruled for the first time
that a man arrested on a covered ward in
Scotland is an American rape suspect who
faked his own death the court Sheriff
has decided that the man calling himself
Arthur Knight is in fact Nicholas Rossi
an American fugitive Mr Rossi is wanted
in connection with sex attacks in Utah
by the Evans of fingerprint photographic
and tattoo evidence taken together
supported by the evidence of changes of
name that Mr Knight is indeed Nicholas
Rossi the person sought for extradition
by the United States
I would have been prepared to accept the
fingerprint Evans alone are sufficient
for that purpose and equally I would
have been prepared to accept the
photographic facial identification
evidence and tattoo evidence taken
together as sufficient for that purpose
I therefore require to answer the
question in section 78 for a of the act
in the affirmative the person appearing
before me is Nicholas Rossi the person
whose extradition is requested by the
United States
who's at the Edinburgh Sheriff Court
this is just an extraordinary case
Connor and the sheriff saying today it
is him
yeah one of the most bizarre cases ever
to be heard in a courtroom in this
country there has been a week of
explosive evidence here at Edinburgh
Sheriff Court essentially the sheriff as
you were hearing just there has been
trying to identify once and for all who
the man behind the mask really is is it
Nicholas Rossi or is it Arthur Knight an
Irish off orphan who has never set foot
in the United States of America while it
was clear today it is Nicholas Rossi The
Fugitive the man who faked his own death
and went on the run to escape a number
of sex charge allegations in the United
States of America he even went as far as
creating a fake obituary he had a
community rallying behind him to mourn
his passing well the court here today
said that that simply was not the case
and it all relied on a string of expert
Witnesses who gave evidence this week
there were distinctive tattoo news on
Nicholas Rossi the Interpol red notice
circulated to police worldwide
distinctive tattoos on his biceps the
nurse who gave evidence said that she
led police to his bedside while he was
undergoing treatment for Coronavirus
last year at a hospital in Glasgow and
they wear the same tattoos Nicholas
Rossi said they weren't on me before I
went in to a hospital for covert and my
body was tattooed during those
proceedings when it came to his
fingerprints again at the same
fingerprints on that Interpol red notice
Nicholas Rossi's excuse in that case was
that an NHS employee came into the
hospital took his fingerprints and
handed them to a corrupt law enforcement
official in the United States the
sheriff was absolutely crystal clear
today he said those claims were
scandalous they were implausible and
they were indeed highly suspicious this
is a long-running case that has
attracted worldwide attention and it
will continue to a full extradition
proceedings in the new year